[Music]
do you think all this money
it's even if it touches money for 6 000
years somebody
reversed that and eliminated that
economic law
well it's it's you know it's an asset
the biggest misconception about gold is
that it's a speculative element
the biggest misconception is that gold
is the cause of financial panics and was
the cause of the great depression that's
simply not true people always compare
gold to stocks that's just
nonsense the majority of people don't
have any understanding about gold
at all the biggest misconception about
gold
is that it's no longer money the idea
that a bureaucrat a
president could say in i-71 the goal is
not money and therefore it isn't after 4
000 years the bureaucrats control money
is an absurdity to anyone who studied
history and understands economics
[Music]
gold is a financial asset which
polarizes opinion like no other
to many it represents the one true money
but whether you believe in it or not
gold has somehow outlasted
every alternative currency for thousands
of years
i'm grant williams and in this series
i'm going to explain how
and why gold became money show you what
it takes to find and produce an ounce of
gold
and examine its place in the modern day
financial system
we'll look at the history of the gold
standard show you how gold is bought and
sold around the world
and you'll witness the extraordinary
measures people take to keep it safe
when i'm done i hope you'll have a
better understanding as to exactly why
this curious yellow metal
has been the source of such fascination
for mankind for thousands of years
[Music]
gold's place as money has run deep
within the fabric of society
since it was first discovered thousands
of years ago
but how and why did this curious yellow
metal
find itself at the center of the
financial universe
gold has been money for 4 000 years and
one of the most fascinating things about
that is that nobody knew why
gold is money until about 100 years ago
everyone just did it
the market it was an emergent property
of the market but no one decided
uh let's use gold what the kings of
judea had not sit down and say let's use
gold it just
came out of the market the history of
the world is the story of gold
so said canadian billionaire eric sprott
unique in its endurance and rarity gold
has been valuable throughout the history
of mankind
when molten iron formed the earth's core
it pulled most of the gold on the planet
down with it
the gold in the earth's core could make
a 13-inch coating across the entire
planet's surface
but of course it could never be
recovered
for the earlier civilizations gold was a
store of value
a medium of exchange as well as a thing
of beauty for the egyptians gold
represented the sun
their gods their rulers and eternal life
the incas described gold as the tears of
the sun and the greek author homer
in the iliad and the odyssey saw gold as
wealth for humans and the glory of the
immortals
the first use of precious metals as
money took place around 700 bc
with coins struck by the merchants of
lydia which were actually formed from a
naturally occurring mixture of gold and
silver
known as electrum gold's unique
properties
enabled the templars to create the first
banks in 13th century europe
as people were able to store their gold
in one bank and borrow against it
elsewhere as they traveled across the
continent
gold's role as money and the universal
acceptance of its value
enabled mankind to build a vibrant
economy that transcended both borders
and cultures it allowed new worlds to be
discovered and settled
and enabled trade to spread across the
globe but today we find ourselves in the
first period of human history
in which no country on earth has a
currency backed by goal
so why does gold retain its importance
in the modern day financial system
if it's no longer money i would argue to
begin with the gold is still money
it's one of many forms of money it is
a medium of exchange and a store of
value unlike
other forms of money including fiat
currencies and cryptocurrencies
and in that context the gold market
trades billions of dollars a day
so to describe it as something other
than money is a bit of a mistake
there was a point in time in certain
societies when the only money was gold
were past that point in time gold is a
competing currency
it is in fact payment rather than a
promise to pay most money is a promise
to pay
rather than being payment in and of
itself gold is extremely important
because throughout history gold is the
only
money that has survived throughout
centuries and even you take two thousand
years back
governments have always destroyed the
value of fiat money or paper money or
silver money at the time of the romans
to the extent
that it has become worthless gold is
important today
because it says it's store value and in
the moment
at the moment we have a real dearth of
reliable stores of value i mean if you
can if you can
think of what gold represents that
financial assets don't represent for
example
is it scarce it's independent
it's not anybody's obligation it's not
anybody's liability it's not drawn on
anybody
it doesn't require anybody's imprimatur
to say whether it's good better and
different
or to refuse to pay it is what it is and
it's in your hand
so in in a world where financialization
and securitization
has essentially converted a lot of
things even real estate
into securities which are merely
obligations
claims uh which are intermediated
through multiple layers
of financial uh institutions but there
are times when they cannot perform
the one thing that we have with gold is
that it you know it can't be
replicated you know by by turning on a
well a printing press or or really
adding a couple of zeros to a bank
ledger
you can't print more of it which makes
it a better money
if it's not money why does the us have a
thousand tons why does the imf
have three thousand tons why has russia
tripled its gold reserves in the last uh
ten years
why is china buying every piece of gold
that's not nailed down and
the largest mining product in the world
and zero exports
so the reasons why gold remains money
are essentially the same
as they've been for centuries and while
to many people's confusion a lot of
those reasons are based
on faith the idea of faith in a timeless
physical asset which has proven its
worth since the dawn of civilization
is perhaps less confounding than the
faith shown in the central bank
governors
of the modern day monetary system who
can conjure trillions of fiat currency
units
out of thin air at will but what was it
about gold and silver which led to those
two elements becoming money
well to answer that question all we need
is a periodic table
and a big red marker pen
first of all we can remove all the gases
obviously we can't use things like
hydrogen or argon as money
next we can remove elements such as
calcium and sodium
which dissolve in water and also
anything that reacts with air
whether it corrodes or bursts into
flames neither of which is a suitable
thing to keep in your pocket
this removes 56 elements
then of course we need to eliminate
anything radioactive because
well quite simply you don't want your
money to kill you
and perhaps surprisingly this
disqualifies 45 elements
now if you've been keeping up that
leaves us with just five so-called
precious metals
gold silver rhodium platinum
and palladium neither rhodium nor
palladium were discovered until the 18th
century
so that rules them out as early money
and the problem with platinum
is its melting point of around 3000
degrees celsius
which was far out of reach of mankind's
earliest furnaces
all that leaves us is gold and silver
and it was these two
precious metals which mankind adopted as
both stores of value
and mediums of exchange
despite the fact that gold is no longer
used as currency
its characteristics as a store of value
remain untarnished
however if you want to store a valuable
asset you have to do so in a way that
protects it
to most people storing gold is thought
to be a cumbersome and expensive process
but the reality is somewhat different so
how do you buy gold
and once you do so where is the safest
place to store it
gold has to be stored outside of the
institutions against which
it serves as insurance or against the
collapse of which or the problems of
which
it serves as insurance and obviously it
has to be stored in a way where
you personally have ability to access it
many people myself included prefer to
hold gold
in secure storage and they prefer to
hold it outside the political
jurisdiction
in which they live because they regard
it as insurance
among other things against the
depredation
of their own government if it's physical
it's allocated
and segregated then you don't really
care it's then down to the quality
institute
that are holding it and the quality of
their security measures that they have
while an individual can easily store up
to half a million pounds of gold bullion
in a simple safety deposit box
there are places in the world which are
home to the gold which makes up the
wealth of nations
and secret vaults which house the gold
at the planet's wealthiest individuals
chooses their means of preserving
intergenerational wealth
one of those vaults is buried deep
beneath the swiss alps
it's home to billions of dollars of
privately held gold and has never before
been
but we were granted permission to take a
look inside one of the world's most
secretive locations
to show you the length mankind will go
to in order to keep this most precious
of metals safe
so we're here today in the biggest
private gold vault in the world
and here gold is stored for wealthy
families for institutions for
private banks and even for some central
banks
when you come through this vault you go
through a number of security zones
you're deep in the mountain here you
we've gone
for miles or kilometers through various
security zones
and different levels deep in the swiss
mountain
to reach actually where the gold is
stored
it is the only vault in the world which
is nuclear bomb proof
earthquake proof gas attack proof
has a security level that doesn't exist
anywhere in the world
i've lost count of how many doors i've
gone through i have no idea how far i've
walked
and i find myself in the middle of a
mountain somewhere in switzerland
and it's only when you get to a place
like this that you understand the
lengths that people go to to protect
this yellow metal the security you have
to put in place
the things you have to do to keep it
protected
this idea of the preservation of
purchasing power is central to the
notion of buying gold as a store of
wealth
and it's been a proven strategy which
has transcended history
as mankind has debased hundreds of paper
currencies over the centuries
gold has remained as the anchor at the
heart of the financial system and the
reasons for that
are the unique properties which made it
money in the first place
gold's durability portability
fungibility and divisibility have
combined to make sure that it's
maintained its purchasing power
outlasting every fiat alternative for
almost 6 000 years
[Music]
through booms and busts through war and
famine and through mankind's constant
ability
to debauch and devalue fiat alternatives
while the dollar has been the world's
reserve currency for 40 years that
hasn't always been the case
the british pound the spanish peseta and
even the portuguese escudo
at one point in history were all as
mighty in their time
as the dollar is today throughout
history when civilizations needed to
finance expansion
they were constrained by their gold
reserves the romans physically clipped
their coins
reducing the amount of gold and silver
and thereby reducing the wages paid to
their armies
until such point that the soldiers
refused to fight
for the majority of the last 200 years
the world has been on a gold standard of
some sort
but we live in the first period in
recorded history of a purely fiat
currency regime
that regime began when richard nixon
broke the dollars linked to gold
in 1971
today the absence of any link to gold
has allowed governments to increase debt
to
completely unsustainable levels when
society can no longer service this
ever-expanding debt mountain
a return to a gold standard of some sort
is almost inevitable
we've all lived in a purely fiat
monetary system since richard nixon's
supposedly temporary suspension of the
dollar's convertibility into gold
and because of that the idea of a return
to a gold standard of some sort
is seen as both unthinkable and
unworkable
the gold standard has been blamed for
the great depression and many prominent
politicians and economists
have claimed that a gold standard would
be impossible in today's world
the question is why what was the gold
standard
and why does the very idea of its
reinstatement stir up such passion
in the hallowed halls of governments and
central banks
we had no central bank from 1836 to
1913. that was one of the greatest
periods of prosperity in world history
forget american history i mean
invention you know the telephone the the
reaper the the airplane
radio phonograph uh massive increase
electricity massive increases in
productivity
great industrial uh successes andrew
cronin
so america grew like crazy with no
central bank
first of all is voluntary you as a
nation could choose to be on it or not
um a lot of countries found it in their
interest to do so
and all you had to do is okay we we
print money we have this paper money
but it's redeemable for gold at a fixed
rate and you sort of
declared that that was your policy and
you stayed with it now
if a whole bunch of currencies are
convertible to gold at a fixed rate
then through a simple transit of law
they're convertible into each other at a
fixed rate
um and that was how the world worked
again with no
no guidance from bureaucrats and if you
ran a trade uh
deficit you had to pay for that in gold
but what happened when you had to pay
for that in gold where you were
decreasing your money supply
that was deflationary prices went down
wages might have gone down for that
matter but that made you more
competitive and then you would
come back to a trade surplus because all
of a sudden you were the chief provider
likewise if you were running a trade
surplus and you were getting all this
gold
what happened your money supply
increased that was inflationary
your prices went up you were less
competitive so this was a self
equilibrating system
the gold standard was a method
that tied the political classes and the
voter
to reality with regards to the
construction
of an economy untied
to arithmetic we've had
a number of occasions when when a gold
standard basically
broke down it but it was never because
of the system never because of the gold
it's always been because of politicians
breaking the gold standard
the gold standard didn't work
because it didn't allow the spenders
to plunder the savers the politicians
were of course
instrumental in that it wouldn't work
today because the political class
doesn't want any part of a system that
constrains their power
there's an article an editorial in new
york times actually that they point in
the 50s it pointed out that
it didn't fail it was killed it was
killed by the
uh power the allied powers uh because
they wanted to fight war
before one broke out the the the
consensus was the general consensus was
that the war couldn't last more than a
few months
because there was certainly wasn't
enough money for the government to fight
the war and of course that that view
didn't understand the first thing the
governments would do was cancel
the right of redemption and print the
money to fight the war
there were five people kind of in the
room at camp david
that weekend was august 15 1971 richard
nixon went up to camp david with his
you know economic team uh it was it was
paul volcker
who was deputy secretary of the treasury
at the time
arthur burns who was chairman of the fed
john conley was secretary of the
treasury
president nixon and there was a fifth
man and for many years i never knew who
the fifth man was i couldn't figure it
out
turned out to be a friend of mine
kenneth damas the the dean emeritus of
the university of chicago law school
i spoke to volcker i spoke to ken dam so
i spoke to
two of the five people who were there
most involved with the decision
and they all taught me the same thing
which is they really thought it was
temporary
so a monetary system which had endured
for thousands of years
was terminated by the stroke of a
president's pen
but what changed when nixon shut the
gold window removing the dollar's anchor
and how has that affected the way we
think of money today
the world changed tremendously after
nixon closed the gold window
up until that point effectively
in the immediate aftermath of world war
ii you had the bretton woods system
where
uh the dollar uh was uh valued at 35
was tied to gold at 35 an ounce and the
rest of the world's currencies were tied
to the dollar and so what you had
was a system where the dollar was
effectively
uh as good as gold they shot the gold
window and they thought well
let's get ready to reopen it tomorrow
um and and see you know just just in
case everyone sort of
there's a run on the dollar or you know
people lose confidence in
in the in the monetary system let's get
ready to reopen the window
pretty much immediately so really he was
sending up a balloon you know
let's try this policy because we've
really run out of money and the other
option is is to actually run a a much
tighter physical system it wasn't the
actual fact of closing the window that
that changed anything it was the fact
that everybody else accepted it
right if everybody had said what
you know dollar piece of paper forget it
no and the dollar you know collapsed or
you know people stopped
accepting treasury bills then then we'd
still have the gold gold center but it's
the apathy of of the general population
at large that caused or that allowed
nixon to get away with this
this this change if you think back to
1971 and decide
whether on a global basis more people
trusted nixon or more people trusted
gold
the circumstance where gold rose in
dollar terms from 35 dollars to 850
dollars
tells you something about the franchise
enjoyed by nixon and the franchise
enjoyed by gold
so what really happened to gold nothing
what happened to the us dollar in the
ensuing 40 years
catastrophic the entire financialization
of the system
came about because of this
soft default on on on u.s treasuries
that happened in 97 of course it's a
soft default
because it was a temporary suspension of
the
of the convertibility of the dollar and
i.e they still owe that gold
so in common parlance when nixon uh
abandoned the gold center that is called
in august of 1971 the idea is that
a gold stopped being money because the
dollar wasn't tied to it there were
people
people who thought gold would collapse
without the monetary demand gold to go
away is absolutely crazy
because of course it was a dollar's
connection a gold that stabilized the
dollar not the other way around
so far in our journey we've seen how and
why gold became money
and over many centuries gold has proven
itself a far superior
store of value than any fiat currency
but there's another story that needs
telling
the story of mankind's relentless quest
to find gold
and extract it from increasingly
difficult places and then to turn it
into the jewellery
bars and coins with which we're all
familiar
milton friedman uh said and warren
buffett likes to quote this that
mining gold is insane you dig up the
gold in one part of
the world you transport it and bury it
somewhere else in different hole and
any marsh in washington's be scratching
his head of course it's a little odd to
say
that an activity in which man has been
engaged without interruption
for four to ten thousand years uh is
insane it seems a little far-fetched
people do do insane things for short
periods of time but not usually for 10
000 years
gold is among the rarest of all the
elements it weighs 19 times more than
water
and is twice as heavy as lead but it
makes up only three parts per billion of
the earth's crust
that's the size of the challenge to find
this most precious of metals
since the dawn of civilization mankind
has been forced into ever more
extraordinary lengths
to extract gold from the earth's crust
so let's take a look at the evolution of
how gold has been mined
over the last thousand years the
earliest gold was found in riverbeds as
miners diverted streams to reveal the
gold beneath
in fact the ancient greeks believed that
gold was a combination of water and
sunlight because it was found in rivers
[Music]
placer mining involved swirling water in
circles in shallow metal pans
with soil from the riverbed leaving gold
as it was washed away
back in 1200 bc enterprising early
miners would also use water power
to propel gold-bearing sand over the
hind of a sheep which would trap the
tiny but heavy flakes of gold
when the fleece had absorbed all the
water it could the golden fleece would
then be hung up to dry
and beaten until all the gold had fallen
off hence the legend of the golden
fleece
a number of early civilizations used a
variation of this technique called
winnowing
in which soil was bounced on woolen
blankets allowing the wind to blow away
the lighter sand
and thus freeing the gold
[Music]
once the easily accessible gold on the
surface had been collected
prospectors needed to start thinking
about how to work lower down
beneath the earth's crust they went and
this required miners to work together
in larger groups as they started digging
underground
amazingly underground mining dates back
as far as the romans but the real
challenge for gold miners was to move on
from primitive methods of extracting
gold from the soil
to developing machines of increasing
sophistication which allowed them to
mine gold from the hard rock below the
earth's surface
early days of quartz rock mining were
relatively straightforward as far as the
shallow deposits were concerned
but until the 1860s the maximum depth
miners could reach was around 300 feet
the sheer size and scale of the economic
and geological challenges faced by early
miners
meant it would take many years of
technological progress to enable deeper
oil to be reached
hardrock miners would sink shafts in
order to extract gold from the quartz
rock
drilling was either done by hand or
through the use of compressed air drills
with the help of a little dynamite
hydraulic drills were the next evolution
and these helped open up deeper holes in
the earth's surface
using drill bits which became longer and
thinner the further they went down
larger rocks extracted from the mines
were crushed by heavy iron stamping
machines
to release the gold from the surrounding
rock hydraulic mining
used high pressure jets of water to
displace the rock and soil
and open up the gold beneath high in the
hills
water was diverted into ditches and
through heavy iron pipes
as the water channeled down gravity
increased its pressure and as that
pressure reached around 5000 pounds per
square inch
it was pushed through a small nozzle and
used to blast the mountains apart
the displaced soil cascaded down the
valley and into the sluices below
where it would be separated this new
mining technique whilst productive was
not without cost however as diverting
all that water
caused huge flooding in the valleys
below devastating farmland
as a solution to this problem in
california miners turned to dredging
which worked like a vacuum cleaner
sucking up the material underwater and
running it through a sloughs to sift out
the gold
for gold has gotten increasingly
difficult over the last 50 years
not just in finding the deposits
themselves but due to the increased
social
political and environmental factors
shaping the mining landscape
but how has that affected the way
deposits are discovered and what are the
added risks
now that we're looking deeper and deeper
into the earth it's getting
much more complex to find
much more complex to recover metallurgy
and now we have to deal with issues to
do with social situations environmental
situations
so the cost of finding these things has
just gone up
exponentially and the difficulty is of
finding a new deposit as as well back in
the 80s
a new technology was developed in nevada
for heat sleep
reach recovery which meant that you
could take low grade
oxidized ore and oxidized means
basically the the gold used to be in
pyrite iron
and it rusted when it rusted that turns
the pyrite to rust
that liberates the gold so you could you
sprinkle a cyanide solution on it
that dissolves the gold and you could
recover so that was a whole revolution
we've gone through that those deposits
are mostly gone now
um the next revolution in in discovery
was when the iron curtain fell and the
whole world basically opened up to
exploration as geologists
and we could go to places and walk up to
outcropping ore bodies that nobody had
ever
looked at satellite imagery came in and
by different different metals
different clays produce a different
spectra
a light spectrum and you could see that
and process it and you could find areas
of alteration
and you go straight to that so that was
sort of the big revolution in the 90s
and subsequent to that there's been no
revolution it's just gotten much much
harder to find these things
all the discoveries are happening deeper
and deeper and deeper in the earth
and that brings a bunch of a lot of a
lot of issues in terms of
finding those things because really
we're looking blind the truth is
that the technology involved in finding
gold
has progressed traditional methods of
gold and the traditional deposit styles
that we mined 200 years ago
are tough to find because we already
found them and mined them
but the industry is doing a reasonably
good job of finding new deposits
the challenges now is that the easy to
find deposits
are often found in political
jurisdictions that strike the people
that have the money to go find gold
as being risky political jurisdictions
i find myself financing the exploration
for gold
in places like congo sudan
kyrgyzstan myanmar bolivia
places that most people normally
wouldn't choose to go on vacation
that's their mistake by the way you know
people always say well
mine is really risky because it's it's
really hard to find something you know
the expiration phase is really risky
only one out of a thousand
prospects ever becomes a mine so that's
pretty risky
you know it offers an awful lot of scope
for shareholders to lose a ton of money
and so it gets known to be a very risky
business
but believe me when you're in the mining
business
the risk begins when you find an
economic deposit
once once you've found a deposit what do
you do well you have to do a whole bunch
of technical studies to make sure you
can mine it
and make money at it make make money so
it's actually or not waste
and that takes a lot of technical skills
you have to have geologists
engineers metallurgists you then have to
have a whole bunch of
lawyers making sure you've got your
title right you've got your surface
rights you've got your
social license and all your all your csr
people your environmental
studies you've got to get all that right
you've got to get your permits so you
have
you have you know you have expiration
risk you have feasibility risk
is this going to be feasible you have
price risk
i mean the gold price can swing or the
silver price can swing
you know 50 percent in a single year
i've seen it happen i've seen it go with
the gold price and go from 300 to 450
in a year the silver price goes from
five dollars to ten dollars a year you
can have the most brain
you know genius level of metallurgist in
your company and they can still get it
wrong you can use a new method and it
doesn't work on that particular ore
and finally you can get in the ground
you can finally start digging it up
and guess what all of your economic
studies are based on drill holes
the drill holes might be you know a
couple hundred feet apart or they might
be 30 feet apart
and then you have social risk you've got
to have your social license
right now in the world there's all sorts
of places that do not want mining
for whatever reason they don't want
mining for indigenous reasons having to
do with
the social nature of the tribal
peoples in areas that that have never
had money they just simply don't want
money there it happens in canada it
happens in brazil
happens it happens in africa all over
the world mines are where you find them
they're in great places and they're in
terrible places and you just have to
take them where
where they are it's a highly risky
business the first thing i do when i go
to a new project is
you pick up the rock but what you really
do is is
look around say okay where am i what's
the infrastructure what's going to take
to get
in here to build to build this thing is
there a road is there power
is there water is there a church sitting
on top of the deposit
these things cost hundreds of millions
to billions of dollars
and on top of that you're dealing with
okay what's the political situation here
you know we've seen just this year
guatemala tanzania
the philippines and indonesia throw
taxes or pole mines or whatever
on projects that were built or being
built or operating
so that's a respect you've got to throw
into it
um and then you're you're predicting
as you know your company you're
predicting what's the gold or copper
price going to be 10 years from now when
this thing's operating
the risks involved in finding and
building a gold mine are just the
beginning
the risks of investing in junior mining
companies are every bit as fraught for
investors
as those faced by the men and women
trawling the earth's crust in search of
deposits
mining companies need to make
predictions about the costs of their
mines
as well as the future value of the metal
they'll eventually be able to pull from
the ground
but investors not only have to evaluate
these variables but also make a
calculated prediction
about the ability of the company's
management to successfully navigate the
treacherous path from discovery to
production
the chances of success are frighteningly
low and new deposits are proving
increasingly difficult to find
when you're investing in junior
exploration companies
my job is to find the fatal flaw as soon
as possible
newmont did a study a number of years
back where
they estimated that one in a thousand
prospects
turn into a mine of some sort and are
one in ten thousand
turn into a tier one deposit now those
odds sound really bad
and it's not that bad because it's easy
to screen out the crap
but it's still really long odds i mean
looking at gold we
as an industry produce about 90 million
ounces a year
we haven't found 90 million ounces since
2006. right now we're averaging about
20 million ounces a year so there's a
real deficit
because you look at their production
profile and two three four five years
out it drops off
but you got to consider it takes
for a large deposit to be drilled out
studied and built 10 to 20 years
so anything we find today we've got to
think 10 years down the road
more or less it'll be in production
there's unpriced optionality there
because there's going to be an m a wave
at some point there has to be
because the largest companies have been
depleting reserves and overfist
and will have to come to the market to
to buy some of the sorts of names that
we buy you always buy
a fund or an index do not buy an
individual stock
because the risk rewards skew is
completely wrong it doesn't there's no
logic in doing that you must buy
um you must limit your downside risk by
having an index
which will also maintain 75 80 of your
upside potential so that's
that's the first point the second is to
understand what is it that moves them
so while yes there's an expiration phase
where you can make 10 times your money
if someone drills something out and it
looks
way bigger than people thought that's
fine but for me it's about
um gold and silver mining companies are
mining margin
that's what they're doing the fact that
a lump of yellow metal can command a
price of over one thousand dollars an
ounce
is a source of mystery to many people
but when you look at the cost of
exploration
as well as the cost of the labor and
energy which goes into extracting it
from the ground
to say nothing of the taxes and the
regulatory burden it becomes much
simpler to understand gold's value
but there is a point at which every
deposit in the world becomes
uneconomical to mine
and when that point is reached the
decisions that have to be made
have far reaching consequences so
there's an expression minds die
hard they really are hard to kill
and they're hard to kill because when
you have a mind that
let's just say is losing money that's
that's an economic reason to close a
mine
you might have a thousand people whose
livelihoods depend on running that mine
you have you have if it's an underground
mine you have a lot of maintenance costs
to keep that mind going if you close it
you have to de-water it constantly you
have to keep the power on you have a lot
of equipment you have to maintain
an open pit mine you can do less
expensively but it still does have care
and maintenance costs and sometimes
those care maintenance costs
are way higher than running the mine in
a loss for a period of time
so mine's die hard it takes a long time
to close the mind and most companies
will
end up losing money for a long time
before they bite the bullet and say this
is hopeless
miners are very optimistic people as a
rule we're we're born optimists
otherwise we wouldn't be in this
business
while it may be true that every minor is
a born optimist this optimism and this
willingness to go to dangerous places in
search of untold riches
is certainly not without its dark side
i've had cerebral malaria i've had
toxoplasmosis various parasites that
have almost killed me i've had
helicopter crashes i was in a plane
crash that destroyed the plane and i had
to climb up the window
i've fallen in crevasses i've i've been
in riots i almost was killed in liberia
in a ride in liberia i've been tear
gassed in bolivia god knows how many
times
i mean and of course the the real car
you know what the real carnage is in the
exploration industry
it's it's cars it's it's it's bad roads
in bad places and people get in
accidents and cars and so
how many how many geologists that i know
and actually have worked with in my
company who have died in car crash i can
count them
on two hands which is a lot three guys
from my class have been shot
in in hot places uh
two of them were shot in and getting out
of a helicopter in philippines in
mindanao
uh and one was killed in south america
in a in a
you know by bad guys it's a very
dangerous business
but i love it so much that i embrace
that kind of risk and it's worked for me
and i'm still alive and
so you know here we are the challenges
associated with finding and mining this
strange yellow metal
increase every year and as the process
has evolved over the last half century
mining company ceos are finding those
challenges harder and harder to solve
[Music]
the mining industry has been a hard
industry to operate in for the last 30
years
and the aura of respect surrounding
mining
is somewhere below that surrounding
garbage collection
and the consequence of that is that many
competent people would choose a job in
any career
other than mining the people that you
see in the executive ranks of mining
companies
are largely of my generation which is to
say
old while they have experience we're
beginning to lack
legs in the industry the biggest
challenge i think that gold
mining ceos have today is that
none of them that i've met and i've met
dozens or hundreds of them
really understand what gold is they mine
gold as if it were copper as if it were
10 as it were other things
uh and and you should mine go in a very
different way because gold is a very
different dynamic given
its stock to flow ratio and given the
fact people hoard gold they don't
uh consume it if you go back uh before
the 70s
when people understood gold uh the
impetus was to have your gold mine
last as long as it could uh and and
again this this is something that no
mining ceo that i have ever come across
understands and because they're trained
to to look at it as another commodity
and it isn't and as a result
the whole entire gold mining industry
is is uh is massively uh
misallocates its its capital let's say
it's
one gram per time is equivalent
basically to one part per million
so what we're saying is that with in a
million
grains of sand one of those grains of
sand is going to be gold
so it's not much not much at all
but that can make money that's sort of
the scale we're looking at
and the complexities involved in
figuring that out is
unbelievable because consider we're
drilling a hole
300 meters down into a lower body
looking from our bus it's going to be
you know 100 200 meters wide etc
your drill hole covers an area that big
you cut that in half crush that half of
the core
down and then you extract a 30 gram
sample and that 30 gram sample whatever
that is
is meant to represent an area 25 by 25
by 25.
so you can kind of see the complexity
and issues we deal with here
the first time i found a gold mine
a bunch of times i thought i did but
didn't but the first time i actually did
i was working in honduras funded by some
guy out of australia and
working on this conceptual idea of these
hot springs
that are forming gold deposits i went
you know got the geologic maps which
were pretty poor and in fact at that
point in honduras
you could only get a map from the
government and they cut all sorts of
bits and pieces out of it so it's really
difficult
and what i saw on the map was la
templardero which is bubbling hot spring
so i went there and found a big outcrop
of solidified britsheaded
center which is hot springs deposit
and that never carried anything it was
much gold in that yet on the sides on
the fault
over here in this rock type resulted all
the hell
it uh i started picking up some good
numbers you know seven eight grams gold
you're like a detective you're trying to
figure out what happened
on this piece of ground a million ten
100 million
you know billion years ago based on a
little bit of data so it's always
fascinating to me just
figuring that sort of thing out and if
you get it right
it's it's it's it's incredible feeling
like wow
you know i got it right it's working it
doesn't happen that often
but as a geologist i mean that's what i
love it you know no matter where i go in
the world
i've always got rocks to look at and
think at and i like that
gold is unique amongst the elements in
that it isn't consumed like say
silver its value makes even the tiny
amounts of gold
using things like electronics economical
to recover
and this means that importantly just
about every ounce of gold
ever mined remains above ground gold is
not consumed
all the gold ever mined in human history
still exists above ground
somewhere maybe buried in a pyramid
perhaps
but available at the right price it
comes back into the market and what that
means is that what gold mining does is
it
adds gold an enormous gold of above
ground supply of the metal already
and so when we think about gold mining
uh it's very unlike
oil production or copper modeling or
iron ore mining
because those commodities are consumed
very shortly after their mine which gold
is not
now gold production has actually
increased significantly over the past
150 years
with the advent of new technologies and
new deposits that are found but
interestingly if you look at
the percentage increase the background
supply has been fairly stable at between
one and three percent
at the moment the best best guess is
probably that there are
187 000 tons of gold
so this is all the gold that that ever
was mined
this is the stock but you could also
call it the inventory
and then there's the flow the flow is at
the moment i think in 2016
mine production was 3200 tons
so 187 000 tons of stock 3
200 tons of flow if you divide that
you arrive at 58.8
i think that's a stock to flow ratio
that
means that um if if you continue
producing at the same rate
it would take 58 years to double
the stock of 187 000 tons of gold
but that also means that the annual
inflation
of gold is 1.7
which is pretty low and i think it's
interesting that
population growth is also roughly 1.7
now i think when it comes to
to money um trust and stability
is crucial if you compare it to feared
money inflation
since 1971 on average the monetary base
grew at 9 per year since 1913
it grew by 8 per year so
much much more if there would be a major
supply disruption
in the copper space or especially in the
oil space
i mean if if they close down the straits
of hormuz or or whatever
oil supply would last for a couple of
months and would have a huge impact on
gold
on oil prices while for gold
if there's a big strike in in in south
africa and mining production is is down
10 it doesn't have any impact on the on
the price of gold
because of the stock the existing gold
is there people trade with that existing
gold
and and at some price every holder of
gold will become a seller and that's the
beauty of it
and that is also from my point of view
the reason why gold is that liquid
twenty percent of the world's finished
gold products come from a single
refinery in switzerland
in the final part of our journey this
episode we want you to see firsthand
this fascinating process
to understand how the gold extracted
from the ground is turned from a few
flecks and a piece
of rock to a finished gold bar
that what we are doing here um is
actually
really very very old techniques there
has
nothing dramatically new has been
invented
all the technology that we are using
here is known for hundreds
if not four thousand years but of course
it has been refined in the meantime
okay we are now entering the
what we call the black foundry black
because
the material that we are processing here
is still
containing impurities it's mainly the
dory
coming from the mines dory bar
consists of gold and silver and some
impurities
actually we call dory already when it
is uh one or two percent containing gold
and
the resting is mainly mainly silver so
this is high-grade dory
and you see also here this these
drill holes they were made by
the mine by the producer so they know
what they are sending out so we
take these bars into our refinery
as well as also scrap or jewelry
or industrial scrap refine it
that means we bring it up to a fineness
of
up to 99 99.99 percent
pure gold it's a normal procedure
to speed up the melting process
normally we reach 250 degrees
we are ready to pour in 45 minutes
[Music]
we take our samples always out of the
liquid gold because now only then you
are
sure that you have a representative
sample
now we take drillings here from this
sample because
this is representative for the whole
melt and these samples then they go to
our laboratory to the laboratory of the
customer and one is
kept aside in case of disputes or
disputes
so this is the electrolytical refinery
these are
those are anodes we have just made
before
after that we take these ants inside
each electrolytical plant inside the
electrolytical plant we have a
acid current so we dissolve
everything yeah but with a particular uh
setting of current and voltage you can
guarantee that the only pure gold will
be
so this is pure gold pure gold when it
is
coming back from the refinery it is
the first step is we have to prepare the
final bars we have two melting pots
we are heating up in one pot and the
other pot is pouring
and then it solidifies in in this cube
we cut it now into pieces like this
and this is a little bit less than
one kilo
now we are going to what we call the
white foundry
right because it is all pure high grade
fiber
that that is processed here you see here
is this
carousel very low blocks now a robot is
taking one of the blobs
and is adding a little piece on it
our man can take the block
with a little bit less than a kilo
some wire melts it down
uh again here you know you you have the
flame
and it's solidified so oxygen is
burned away he cools it down pushes into
water and that is
the final shiny part
on the other side we i can show you the
100
underground bars are produced fully
by robots and you remember
we had these blocks for the kilo bars
[Music]
this is now the hundred gram bars so
it's a little bit less
than on the graph a robot is taking this
block
putting it on a scale
[Music]
adding some wire but then you see there
in the back
this furnace is
is a tunnel so it is put on a conveyor
belt
uh the block with a little bit of fire
and the conveyor belt is moving it
through this tunnel
and when it comes out it is about embark
right so we have we're talking about
thousands of pieces per day
so this here is the last step
[Applause]
quality control that means we are
checking here
by hand the weight of each bar right
if you want to do it precise there is no
other way
she takes every bar puts it on the scale
and is checking the weight at the end
this lady is the most important part
because she is checking the bar she's
the last person who has it in her hands
before it goes to the customer you have
two big issues
uh in in in our business in refining
one is precision you have to be precise
and the other thing is you have to be
fast
because the value of gold aquila roughly
forty thousand dollars
does not permit us to have this this
metal just laying around
so um the whole
production has to be meticulously
planned no
so every step must be
defined to the last i would say almost
minute
workers have to work hand in hand
to make sure that the metal that comes
in is as
quickly through the process as as
possible
the process of finding extracting and
refining gold
gives it not only its luster but also
much of its economic value
today with fiat currencies all around
the world completely unhinged from any
kind of a monetary anchor
gold's value has arguably never been
higher
there's some magic about gold and to
some degree silver there's some magic
it's the heft it's the feel it's the
warmth it's the color
it's just a beautiful thing and it
always has been beautiful and clearly
it's
the absolute core of the last
well not just several hundred years of
history but probably thousands
this genuinely changes people's lives
there's more about gold than
than it's just like a shiny thing what
is really special
so now we have a better understanding as
to why gold is money
and why no matter what alternatives
mankind dreams up over the centuries
we always return to this curious yellow
metal
we've taken you underground to witness
firsthand the enormous challenges that
confront those who scour the globe
looking for new deposits
and we've traced gold's path from a mere
twinkle in a geologist's eye
to the gold bars and coins that we know
and recognize
as gold gets more difficult to find and
more expensive to produce
the challenges facing those who spend
their lives in search of this most
precious of metals
are constantly increasing since it was
first discovered
gold has held a special place in the
hearts and minds of man
for thousands of years it's provided
stability and a means by which wealth
could be measured
preserved and protected for generations
it remains the only universally accepted
currency and the only store of wealth
impervious to government debasement
in the next episode we'll examine the
different attitudes towards gold in the
east and the west
we'll explain how the gold price is
different from the price of gold
and we'll take a look at how gold is
bought and sold around the world
we'll also ask the question is the price
of gold manipulated and
if so by whom and we'll look at some of
the many legends and conspiracy theories
surrounding the oldest money on earth
join me next time as our journey
continues
[Music]
you